wir haben mit dem mann gesprochen der
das kind gefangen hat und ihm damit das
leben gerettet hat wie groß war die
schlagkraft der junge vier immerhin aus
dem dritten stock es war nicht so
einfach das fangen abzuschätzen weil das
gewicht bei so einem menschen kommt ja
nicht auf einen punkt er verteilt auf
den ganzen körper also auf arme und
beine
es ist ziemlich schwer zu fangen aber
der junge hat das aktiv unterstützt er
ist wirklich perfekt in meinen armen
gelandet und das war es was gezählt hat
ich meine ich bin schnell ich hab gut
funktionierende muskeln eine schnelle
reaktionszeit und schnelle füße ich habe
mal football gespielt und habe immer
gelernt meine hände in die richtige
position zu bringen um ihnen gut runter
zu ohren
es ist wie ein instinkt daher hat sich
gedreht und ist perfekt in meinen händen
gelandet ist genauso gelandet ich hatte
eigentlich mehr angst ist sein körper
irgendwie falsch ankommt
[Musik]
ich meine es ist immer wichtig dass man
bach durchs leben geht
für deine eigene sicherheit und für die
sicherheit von anderen und das hier das
war ein gutes beispiel dafür wie
hilfreich es ist wenn man so etwas immer
erwartet und das ist hilft wenn man
wachsam
marien chor trainiert man diese
schutzfunktion und diese geisteshaltung
hat mir geholfen so schnell und so
zielgerichtet mit situationen wie diesen
umzugehen also einfach die aufgabe lösen
und weiter geht's